Bernie Sanders is increasingly in
trouble mostly with folks who describe
themselves as supporters of Bernie just
a few weeks or a couple of months ago
and part of this was Bernie Sanders
endorsing Joe Biden that enraged some
people on the left and Bernie Sanders
now said in a new interview in in very
definitive terms basically exactly what
I said on Monday about this entire
abolish the police defund the police
thing which was he's not for defunding
the police that some departments need
more money but that many changes in
reforms has to be have to be made and
this was a very wide-ranging interview
with The New Yorker I encourage you to
check out the entire thing but listen
call me a neoliberal right-wing nut but
I agree with Bernie Sanders which
increasingly has people furious with me
as well which is just a strange turn of
events let's look at what Bernie said
Bernie when asked about these defund the
police movement said quote do I think we
should not have police departments in
America no I don't there's no city in
the world that does not have police
departments okay so this is this is just
a hard no on actually getting rid of
police departments fair enough some
people are angry with this but some
folks believe this part is reasonable
Bernie goes on what you need are I
didn't call for more money for police
departments I called for police
departments that have well educated well
trained well paid professionals and too
often around the country right now you
have police officers who take the job at
very low payment don't have much
education don't have much training and I
want to change them so again
Bernie pointing out sometimes police are
underpaid sometimes police are under
trained sometimes the department doesn't
have enough officers to actually do
community policing rather than what I
call cheap policing so that's me
editorializing I'm now adding on to what
Bernie Sanders said Bernie goes on quote
I also called for the transformation of
police departments into understanding
that many police departments and cops
deal every day with issues of mental
illness deal with issues of addiction
and all kinds of issues which should be
dealt with by mental health
professionals or others and not just by
lise officers so again Bernie's spot-on
exactly as I said on Monday
I added mental health training for
officers themselves to better deescalate
adding to police departments more mental
health workers straight-up who can
request support from police if necessary
Bernie goes on to say quote I think we
want to redefine what police departments
do give them the support they need to
make their jobs better defined so I do
believe that we need well-trained
well-educated and well-paid
professionals in police departments
anyone who thinks that we should abolish
all police departments in America I
don't agree
so this is very straightforward I like
that bernie is also pointing out that a
lot of times when we look at funding we
would mostly I believe all agree that
funding for military like elements for
police including certain weapons and
riot gear armed vehicles etc that is
funding that should be cut but cutting
salaries particularly when in many parts
of the country police are dramatically
underpaid including being so underpaid
relative to the cost of living that they
have to live far from the area they are
policing which is not good for the
community I made this point earlier this
week sometimes you actually may need to
increase the amount that is going to
salaries as an example while decreasing
the amount that is going to
militarization and equipment so there
have been two primary reactions to
Bernie Sanders saying this one reaction
is people are furious with Bernie
Sanders once again Bernie sold out again
just like he sold out by endorsing Joe
Biden and to them I say what really
happened here like in other words did
you so misjudge Bernie all of these
years you believed he was the most
honest politician the most genuine
politician the best guy that we needed
and then now in six weeks Bernie says
I'm endorsing Biden and we should vote
for him and defund the police is not
something that you know you need to have
police and now you realize that all
along for the last year two years five
years however long you've supported
Bernie your assessment of him was just
wrong what does that say about your
judgment if that is your reaction now
the other response has been well
you know abolish the police defund the
police it's not literal it's a metaphor
for reform but that is where a lot of
the problem is coming from these
conversations of we've got to defund the
police and abolish dismantle police
departments well that you you do need
police though like who are you going to
call in the middle of the night if
someone burgles your house well no no I
mean I don't actually mean defund or
abolish the police what I mean is the
stuff David Pakman said on Monday well
then maybe we agree but the movement
needs to do better branding because
there are some people who do want to
abolish the police but either way the
right is seizing on it and we're getting
crushed right wing media has spent all
week just arguing about the left wants
to defund and abolish the police when
even a lot of the people saying it don't
actually want to do that so it does to
me seem like Bernie's position might
just be to status quo and not radical
enough for some of Bernie's most ardent
followers that that actually may be the
case even without straw Manning or
mischaracterizing Bernie's position or
without making a personal attack on
Bernie it's possible that Bernie's
position on this issue is just not
radical enough for some of the people
that supported Bernie in 2016 and in
2020 now I saw one other perspective
when researching this I saw some Bernie
supporters who said we don't really
believe Bernie means this so understand
what what the argument is there are some
Bernie supporters who believe that deep
down Bernie does want to abolish the
police but in this interview he's
pretending that he doesn't in order to
mainstream Joe Biden's view which is the
same and that it's sort of like a tactic
in other words Bernie wants to defund
the police but as a posturing move to
help Biden Bernie's lying and pretending
that he doesn't want to defund the
police if you believe that then you
believe that Bernie Sanders is
incredibly dishonest and I don't know
how you could otherwise support him like
if you believe Bernie is actually just
straight up lying in this way that then
you should question why you're even why
you you're even still defending Bernie
in any way I don't know if I'm honest
with you guys and I would never be
anything less than honest with you
I'm actually concerned about how quickly
some Bernie supporters abandoned Bernie
after he endorsed by Dhin and said a few
pragmatic things and a lot of Bernie
supporters abandoned Bernie very quickly
attributed the most bad faith
interpretations to everything that
Bernie has said and done since
suspending his campaign and endorsing
Joe Biden like this was the guy for you
and you abandon him this quickly and say
he's either disingenuous or a shill for
Biden or whatever to me that makes me
question whether you were really that
strong of a Bernie supporter from the
get-go or you were only supportive of
him as far as he was saying the things
you wanted to hear and it wasn't really
Bernie you supported it was Bernie as
long as he says what you want to hear
and then as soon as he doesn't Bernie's
no longer you know the genuine thinker
that you met many many said that he was
I don't know but it is definitely
concerning what we're seeing